section du sud de l'ukraine nous partons
pour au dessin mais c'est là que se
trouve l'envoyé spécial de france 24
gwendoline 2 bono bonjour windows et une
âme on vient de voir la situation à kiev
on vient voir aussi la situation dans
l'est de l'ukraine où en est l'offensive
russe dans la zone où vous vous trouvez
vous
alors voulant leur est peut-être
derrière moi les sirènes d'alerté sonne
en ce moment à odessa ça a été de plus
en plus le cas ces derniers jours car
les troupes heureuse frappes à proximité
pour l'instant de la ville mais pour ce
qui est vraiment du front 1-2 ce front
sud après d'odessa qui se situe vers la
ville de nicolet yves et bien il n'y a
pas de progrès pour l'instant des
troupes russes que nous disait une
source militaire hier c'est que leurs
forces sont en majorité engagés dans des
combats dans la ville assiégée de
marioupol et cela est bien les empêche
de lancer plus d'attac et de lancer
vraiment de grosses opérations sur les
autres parties de la côte où par exemple
les russes et said encerclé de
contourner par le nord cette ville de
nicolet depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant et pour l'instant ils ne font
pas de progrès les forces ukrainiennes
ont frappé l'aéroport de carson carson
ce qu'une ville qui est contrôlé par les
russes qui situe à peu près à une heure
de nicolas yves et au moins trois
hélicoptères russes ont été détruits
donc ce qu'on voit en fait pour
l'instant sur ce front sud ce sont des
forces russes qui sont plutôt dans une
position à défensive et c'est ce qui
protège pour l'instant la ville d'odessa
d'une attaque imminente odessa où on
attend ce matin wendeline de mono pour
ceux qui nous rejoindre est peut-être la
sirène vous avez parlé des résidents de
miccoli fait là il ya une question 116
qui a vécu rentrent c'est celle de
partir ou de rester
oui absolument alors tous les jours
c'est vrai qu'on voit ces bus verts qui
viennent chercher les habitants de
nicolet qui ont pris la décision de
partir la majorité sont situés ce sont
des habitants qui sont situés à côté du
front inquiet la base aérienne vraiment
vers l'est de la ville mais on ne
rencontre aussi beaucoup qui sont
décidés à rester hier nous étions dans
une maternité et nous avons parlé avec
des tout jeunes parents qui nous disait
pour beaucoup qu'il n'avait pas
l'intention de quitter leur maison et
qu'il comptait bien élever leurs enfants
ici donc on le voit il ya beaucoup
d'hésitations beaucoup de questions les
habitants en parle énormément et puis
une autre forme de division qui est
assez frappante dans cette ville de 2 me
colle fc la division entre familles
parce que beaucoup de gens ont de la
famille en russie hier nous discutions
par exemple avec une dame qui vit dans
un quartier qui a été assez assez
durement bombardée par les russes elle
raconté cela à sa soeur qui elle est en
russie et elle nous disait elle ce sont
des conversations très dur et très
triste pour moi car ma soeur ne croient
pas un mot de ce que je veux merci
beaucoup moins doline de beaune ont
envoyé spécial de france 24 à odessa
dans le sud de l'ukraine